we're here at the London Film and comic
convention you've been signing tons of
autographs already how are you enjoying
it I enjoy very much because the first
time I'm in London and signing so I have
a lot of fans all over the world so I'm
very happy to meet them and to say all
the crap for them because I don't think
they without this you'll ever meet me
now it's a great opportunity for the
movie stars and artists to meet with
their fans I think it's very important
to make them feel that were there for
them and where as a human being just
like them so which of the films and the
TV series that you've been in have
people been really talking to you a lot
about today so far of course a lot of
love the Quran because that's very
special legendary movie it's my first
English movie and people just I have so
many fans from the crow then a lot of
them from the actually crank - it's
crazy one they like is like out of my
mind and I don't know how people can
recognize me it's very different from
red corner and then the king and these
are serious roles they like I think also
some people like they watch Lost
entourage which I only did one episode
bye everybody know me from that so I
love the roles have seen those TV shows
which is old Playboy because I was the
first Asian a woman on the cover of
Playboy magazine so a lot of gentlemen
come here for that
nude pictures I refuse to do it when
when Hugh Hefner asked me to do it take
me three months to decide it because I
thought in Asia in China playboy is a
porno you know sorry we don't have that
I come from the most primitive communist
country and and having the cover of a
Playboy magazine and everything I have
three or no plastic surgery nothing so
I'm proud of myself
and they say Playboy's Western man's
Bible so I think on the cover of Playboy
magazines much better much more
honourable than on vulgar than instead
any of them because there's our fashion
it's for style but Playboy is for men or
women that's something actually were
pure and beautiful because our body is a
gift and sculpture from nature from God
whoever you believe higher beings and
they need to be celebrated need to be
proud as a woman and the sensuality of
women is a gift especially for just for
real human being also for movie stars
actors very very important to be
essential to be sexy because that's the
elements and keep people dreaming and
keep them handing romance and fantasy
how did you keep in such fantastic shape
I look at the cookies I'm eating is so
much these every day you deserve if I go
to sleep I eat cookies and I don't do
exercise I just I think I think healthy
I go to Sonora muchas cosas la I think
it is your mind is a Central Station
control every element movement are
balanced your body so if you think
healthy I think your outlook will be
healthy instead of otherwise you'd be
worried I think the outlet also reflect
the internal world
you are so you're skinning to I don't
think you you need everything you're
going through much right weirdest net
we're just we're just beautiful human
beings we think beautifully healthy so
nature reflective aspect to be like this
I like this healthy like this idea of
thinking healthy but eating chips and
chocolate that sounds great you know
you're not like people select the food
to eat
like I start to learn some calories how
much I don't even care about I said oh
this how much they select healthy food
to eat but they forgot to think how they
thoughts to think see that's more
important than the food and I think it
because look how we look right we're
just thinking well you know everything
we want see what do you think about when
you're preparing for a role and if you
got an action role and you've got really
got to be quite intense with your body
in that and gotta throw yourself around
and stuff like the the crow like sky
captain world of tomorrow I'm sure we
are shot in London with the to the log
when is pouch oh and Angelina Jolie so I
have to fight right actually in the
trench to you can see because I'm
wearing like this if I work three days
out I have eight packs it's just so easy
I think I'm in this world anymore in my
previous life I just do a little bit my
hope I don't see I don't work out I just
look like this I think again think
healthy right will you think
exercise exercise when you train your
thing you have to do think just think
and your muscles all to have no kids net
just think don't do see you just there
but he has a constant you think I'm
doing a flip up and running I'm getting
out all of that so you just sink and
intensely we wake up open your eyes
you're all muscle that's what I do then
you can you deserves all this fat food
official body calm I just write a song
called I forgot Hughes Tuesday night a
p.m. well I can't go in my bedroom I
make myself feel sexy I put on my sexy
dress like the way you like
maybe I put on my high-heeled shoes I
walk with my ro I forgot so waiting for
your touch that's that's my son it's
cool I did music video myself I write
song 5 hours the lyrics music record all
by myself
so that's a rock star crazy girl that I
put into music but in real life I'm very
sophisticated very elegant because I
want people to see me as a brilliant
actress that's who I am and very
intelligent I'm not a bimbo even though
I'm on Playboy magazine cover
sophisticated but also sexy it's not
like I'm so physically have to be born
like a librarian right it's not I'm sexy
I'm a dumb right you don't have to be
involved this is more than 20 2012 woman
should be oh it's next to more than 2012
paling I'm very excited to have many
projects I've been shooting like three
movies a film finished last night I got
an offer and before I left a way to God
God offer job I have two offers so I
start from 16 I'm flying to New York
shoot and go to Cambodia so I'm very
fortunate and lucky and I've been
working also I'm working on my own
project so I'm gonna make a film about
contemporary woman its perspective
talking about relationship sex and
contemporary love what is love what is
dating so that's something I'm working
on my own so healthier support me if you
go to official valine comm or follow me
and will Bailey on Twitter and I start
to do also Facebook I refuse to have a
biggest too much work you know every day
you're right I can't keep up but I start
right it's like my diary if you read my
facebook it's like really really I want
a candy no really really fun and also on
Twitter I gave a fat-free sugar-free
fortune cookie which is a little phrase
for you too
it's a little wisdom in life and for you
too to encourage you
and to make you go through difficulties
in your life so now I'm sharing with you
my cookie today is give and forgive I
like it and I'm not no very positive
note thank you very much very long it's
a little early to speak to you enjoy the
rest of the weekend thank you
you